pay on Tick Tock is horrendous now
before you go to the comment section and
leave angry remarks let me explain Tick
Tock only pays about two to four cents
per 1000 views so even if you get a
ridiculous amount of views you're not
making much take cabulame for example he
is the most followed tick tocker on the
planet with a whopping 159 million
followers and a nearly 18 billion views
but in terms of AD revenue from Tick
Tock these 18 billion views only
translates to 540 000 now that's not a
bad amount by any means but keep in mind
we're talking about the most followed
tick tocker in the world for perspective
if you got the same number of views on
YouTube your total earnings would be
closer to 54 million dollars assuming a
three dollar RPM now of course these
tick tockers don't just rely on Tick
Tock ads they also do brand deals and
sponsorships and affiliate marketing and
all that stuff which pulls isn't a whole
lot of money but the disparity between
Tick-Tock ads and YouTube ads is so
staggering I mean we're talking about a
100x difference and it's not just
creators who are feeling the pain Tick
Tock is also very much feeling the pain
having lost 7 a billion dollars last
year alone and it's only getting worse
Vine was facing the same challenge 10
years ago and this is the main reason
that they eventually shut down all of
their most popular viners would
translate their audiences over to
YouTube this included Drew Gooden David
dobrik Danny Gonzalez Cody KOA and of
course Logan Paula and Jake Paul we're
starting to see the exact same thing
happen with tick talkers as well notable
examples are Charlie demilio Bella
Porsche Addison Ray and call me Chris
call me Chris for example has likely
earned about 350 000 on Tick Tock but
she's already made Millions on YouTube
this is a not a great sign for tick tock
in terms of longevity as this is hard
evidence that people are simply using
Tick Tock as a springboard for YouTube
or to jumpstart your music career while
the platform is burning billions so
here's tick tock's monetization crisis
and the uncertain future of the platform
by far the largest shortcoming for tick
tock is advertisers advertisers simply
do not want to advertise on Tick Tock
and it's easy to blame the medium for
disbeluctance most advertisers aren't
used to making short form ads in
portrait mode and this is true to a
certain degree but it's not the main
reason I mean companies like apple and
Coca-Cola have marketing budgets in the
hundreds of millions if not billions and
they have a hundreds if not thousands of
employees whose full-time jobs are to
Simply figure this out so the reason
that companies are reluctant to
advertise on Tick Tock is not because
they don't know how or can't figure it
out it's because they don't want to why
you ask well for one it's not a very
lucrative audience 41 of tick tock users
are between the ages of 16 and 24 which
means that most of them don't have any
money for perspective this is how
YouTube's audience demographic looks as
you can see it's a lot more evenly
dispersed this in itself is a big turn
off for advertisers but the issue goes
much deeper than just demographics
likely the biggest concern for most
advertisers is brand Optics and it's no
secret that the content on Tick Tock is
how should I say it edgy you've got
thirst traps a bunch of cursing and all
this other stuff that YouTube tells you
not to do this is actually what has made
tick tock so popular in the first place
but there's a reason that YouTube
doesn't not lean into this content
advertisers simply do not want to be
associated with this type of content I
mean if you're a apple would you really
want your ad to play after this I'm
gonna guess no
and this makes a far larger difference
than you might think at this point I
think we can agree that Tick Tock is
very much a worldwide platform in 2021
it was literally the world's most
popular domain for crying out loud so
clearly it's extremely popular across
the globe but guess what eighty percent
of tick tock's Revenue still comes from
China and if you didn't know the tick
tock that we use is actually banned in
China you see it the CCP decided that
mainstream tiktok is simply too vulgar
and unproductive for the Youth so
instead they have a healthy version of
tick tock called doyin fundamentally
speaking it's the same app the
difference is the type of content that
is posted and promoted on the platform
doyin primarily promotes science
educational and historical content
instead of lip syncs and dancing
furthermore younger Generations are
limited to just 40 minutes of doyin per
day so no hours of mindless crawling and
doyin is extremely popular in China but
it doesn't quite stack up to tick tock
doyen boasts 730 million monthly active
users while Tick Tock boasts 1.05
billion monthly active users so Tick
Tock is not only more popular but people
tend to spend far more time on Tick Tock
but despite this tainai is able to
account for 80 of tick tock's Revenue
because advertisers are actually
interested in appearing next to Dorian
videos so until Tick Tock is able to
address Advertiser hesitation Tick Tock
will continue to face major monetization
issues leading to more creators
migrating away
[Music]
advertisers no doubt play a massive role
in how much is paid out to creators but
they're not the only issue plaguing Tick
Tock you see it short form content is
simply fundamentally harder to monetize
because a views are worth substantially
Less on Tick Tock for example the
average video is only 36 to 42 seconds
long depending on the size of the
account even if we assume that these
videos have 75 audience retention on
average each view only translates to
about 30 seconds of watch time now
compare that to what we see on YouTube
using myself as an example my average
video gets just under 7 Minutes of
average watch time which by the way
thank you this means that the average
view on my channel is worth about 14
views on Tick Tock why do I bring this
up well monetization has more to do with
watch time than views I tend to put an
ad break once every three minutes which
means that the average view translates
the three ad impressions for Simplicity
let's say that Tick Tock also shows an
added once every three minutes since
each video is only watched for 30
seconds at the best a viewer would have
to scroll through six tick tocks before
reaching an ad and that's the best case
scenario more likely they'll have to
scroll through 10 or 15 tick tocks
before seeing an ad but we'll call it 6
to give them the benefit of the doubt
this means that each view on Tick Tock
only translates to one at sixth of an ad
impression putting this next to YouTube
will see that each YouTube view
translates to 18 times more ad
Impressions so if we want to really
create an accurate comparison between
how much advertisers pay on YouTube
versus how much they pay on Tick Tock we
can't compare views to revenue we have
to compare ad Impressions to revenue
YouTube generally pays three to five
dollars per thousand views in most
niches
and as we previously touched on Tick
Tock only pays 2 to 4 cents per thousand
views but if we normalize based on ad
Impressions we'll see that Tick Tock is
actually paying 36 to 72 cents for the
same number of AD Impressions that you
would get from 1000 YouTube views till
about 7 to 8 times worse than YouTube
but also about 18 times better than what
The Upfront number suggested the only
way to work around this obstacle is to
move towards longer form content which
is exactly what Tick Tock has been
trying to do what started at a maximum
video length of 7 Seconds has grown all
the way to 10 minutes
Tick Tock has also been testing with
landscape mode but increasing the
average view duration isn't as easy as
just getting creators to post longer
videos the algorithm highly values
audience retention so if tick-tockers
wander long from videos to perform well
they have to increase video length
without sacrificing audience retention
also you know how we see all those
articles about our ever decreasing
attention spans well if that's true
anywhere it's true on Tick Tock so Tick
Tock is very much fighting an uphill
battle when it comes to monetization due
to the fundamental nature of their
content
hearing all this you might be saying
that this isn't just an issue on Tick
Tock Instagram and YouTube have also
been promoting short form content so
they should be facing the same issues
right well you're right YouTube and
Instagram are indeed facing the same
issues with YouTube shorts for example
you can expect to earn five cents per
thousand views but here's the thing
YouTube and Instagram are not tied down
by short form content short form content
is not their Golden Goose it's simply an
expansion effort and they're already
starting to decide that this expansion
effort isn't worth it you see platform
monetization is a two-sided coin if
creators aren't earning much money from
ads neither is the platform at least the
creators can go out and get brand deals
and sponsors and Affiliates and all that
for these platforms their only revenue
is AD Revenue so if that's garbage the
entire revenue from the the whole effort
is garbage and that's exactly what seems
to be playing out in fact according to
Mark Zuckerberg revenue from Rios is so
garbage that meta is losing 500 million
dollars per quarter because of users
watching reels instead of scrolling
through pictures yeah I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that meta has
stopped offering Wheels bonuses to
creators so while Instagram and YouTube
are very much in the same position as
Tick Tock with shorts they're also not
they have the luxury of pulling pack and
focusing on what they were already doing
the same cannot be said about Tick Tock
but then what's the solution well
unfortunately for tick tock there is no
clear solution to their monetization
problem again this is literally why Vine
shut down what tick dog really needs is
time they need time for Brands to become
more open with the idea of advertising
on Tick Tock in the meantime their best
to bet is to Tinker with the algorithm
to push longer form content that's more
Advertiser friendly but this is also a
pretty big gamble this can lead to a
sort of at apocalypse like we saw with
YouTube back in 2017. more Educators got
pushed off the platform as
family-friendly content got pushed to
the top but the thing to note is that
YouTube will always had a good mix of
edgy and family-friendly content so the
shift towards family friendly content
was more natural with tick tock on the
other hand we're primarily dealing with
edgy content so the shift is a lot more
jarring and it's not clear how many
viewers Tick Tock would push off the
platform by making such a change but
with their peers are already dropping
out then the pulling back this might be
the Hail Mary that Tick Tock needs to
stay relevant over the long term
[Music]
as you can see Tick Tock is very much
facing a monetization crisis and that
there is no easy solution but there is a
silver lining for tick tock unlike Vine
which was backed by Twitter which in
itself was not a profitable company Tick
Tock is backed by bite dance which has
been posting record profits in fact they
made it 25 a billion dollars last year
so losses from Tick Tock are definitely
something that they can sustain even
over the long term also even if bite
dance can't put off on their own they've
got the backing of the CCP you can bet
that as long as Tick Tock is popular the
CCP won't let them go under as Tick Tock
is literally a gold mine for them so
from a financial perspective they very
much have time on their side but they
may not be able to say the same thing
about their creators or viewers their
creators are naturally pivoting towards
YouTube to build stronger businesses
with more revenue and as per viewers
they could easily migrate back to
YouTube with these creators also Tick
Tock faces the risk of their viewers
growing up but kind of like what
Snapchat is dealing with right now so
what Tick Tock may not be on the clock
for financial reasons they're very much
on the clock due to Trends amongst their
viewers and the creators will they be
able to beat the clock well only time
will tell while all this madness has
been going on with short form content
podcasts have surprisingly been doing
better than ever on YouTube if you want
to learn why check out this video but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one